seventeen-year-old is Mohammed has been
missing school for a week she was
injured during protests in yalla in
South Darfur less than two weeks ago
gizmo says the school released them
early because of a shortage of bread
students from other schools protested
then things turned violent they were
boys burning ties during the protests
the soldiers were firing tear gas at
them and they were throwing the
canisters back at the soldiers we ran
and took a turn and found soldiers
mounted on pickup trucks
some of them fired live ammunition one
of the bullets hit my foot according to
activists here at least half a dozen
students were injured in the two days
the protest lasted they were also angry
about the lack of fuel these shortages
are the same issues that led to the
month-long nationwide protests that
forced President Omar al-bashir from
power the military took over earlier
this year until a transitional power
sharing agreement was signed in August
with protest leaders in Khartoum but
more than six weeks after the deal those
in the Elysee any changes are yet to be
seen and felt it wasn't just bread and
fuel shortages that brought people out
to protest here in Miele has in many
other cities in Sudan there are growing
calls for state governor's to be
dismissed they were appointed earlier
this year by former President Omar
al-bashir and people say that the fact
they're still in power means the old
regime hasn't gone away
activists in miele say there have been
repeated incidents of violence in the
state already marred by conflicts this
day doesn't have been shot by armed men
in the past year and that no action has
been taken against the attackers South
Darfur s governor admits more needs to
be done to provide security no one can
tell people not to protest that's a
right granted to them in the
transitional Constitution agreement
we've secured bread and fuel for the
people now but we admit we are weak when
it comes to security because we have a
lot of counties and not enough security
forces we have spoken to the sovereign
council about that and they've pledged
to increase security forces so people
will feel safe according to the
transitional deal all the military
governor's appointed in February are to
be replaced by civilian governors until
that happens
Nia's Resistance Committee which
organize the protests says it will
educate the city's residents about their
rights an equal sign here was I seen
mere activists in niala say there have
been repeated incidents of violence in
the state already marked by conflict
they said dozens have been shot by armed
men in the past and that no action has
been taken against attackers gizmo says
she knows her rights and was focusing on
that when she went to school the day she
was injured she wants to know why they
were bullets fired when those protesting
had been unarmed and only demanding
bread and the change they've been
promised
Hiba morgan al jazeera neela South
Darfur